- Ah, yes, The MandaLakeran.
I’d know that brow anywhere.
- Here is the bounty you requested.
- Excellent.
Midseason bounties are quite valuable.
We will add him to the collection.
The freezing process has improved over the years.
Somewhat.
- The Hoth Angeles super team is now complete.
- Not quite. There is one more asset I need, from your home planet.
- Naboo Orleans?
- Yes, there is a new threat to our empire there, a child.
As the future of basketball, he belongs in a big market.
Perhaps you should bring the RONDO-9.
- No. The child’s defenders will just sag off the Rondo and double me in the paint.
- I’m here for the Child.
- Ha. There’s three of us and one of you.
Do you really think you’re as strong as three men?
- And three draft picks.
- So long, MandaLakeran.
- Keep shooting like that, they’ll make you a stormtrooper.
You’re the “future of basketball”?
I guess you’re gonna move a lot of merch. Well, let’s go.
We’ve gotta get you below two-seventy.
- Welcome back to “Space Sports Talk.”
Our top story: shocking revelations about former NBA great Obi-Wan Wallace.
- “Obi-Wan Wallace”? I wonder if he means old Ben Wallace.
Leaving there is for your own good.
Basketball once flourished everywhere, but that was before the rise of the Super Team.
I was there for the slaughter of my people in the
2012-2013-2014-2015-2016-2017-2018 and 2019 seasons.
I had no choice but to flee with eighteen months still on my contract.
This is the way.
It’s the Duke Blue Devils! They want you back for three more years!
Hold on, kid.
Kid?
We lost them! How did you do that?
I’ve never seen a ship cut so hard that it tore apart its own landing gear.
I guess you are special.
Too special for LeBron to banish you to the three-point line
I can’t take you to him. There’s only one place to go.
There is no more basketball here. You’ll be safe.
- I wouldn’t count on it.
The RONDO-9 put a tracking device on your ship.
- Damn it. I didn’t search my ship for tropes.
- Now stand at the three-point line while I talk to the Child.
- I won’t let you have him.
- I understand your conflict.
I too once felt the pull of small-market guilt and went back to my home planet.
But all stars belong in Hoth Angeles.
- We couldn’t agree more.
We also left small markets.
But there’s two Super Teams on your planet, LeBron, and we want the Child...
- Come to the Clippers, my son.
- Here I am, Dad!
- Ew, not you.
- He should join the Golden Empire.
- No, mate, he should join The Process.
- Oi, kiddywink, you wanna be part of The Process?
- The Child isn’t going with any of you.
- Get out of here, Popovich.
- No. The Child can succeed anywhere.
I thrived for decades in the barren deserts of San Antooine
- Enough!
For years you tried to sell me on that small-market crap!
- Ow, my thigh! I’m out for five games—maybe a season!
- Run. And take the Child with you.
- There’s too many of them. We can’t escape.
- Yes, we can. I’ll coach the RONDO-9.
- What?
- If you try to coach a RONDO-9, it self-destructs.
RONDO-9, play within the offense.
- Initiating self-destruct.
- Run!
- Don’t worry, I’m sure Popovich will come back as a ghost.
So, kid, where should we go now?
Home? But you can’t win there.
- Small market make big, I will.
- I am the real Chris Paul.
- Man, this guy even follows me into space.
Don’t fall for mind tricks. You want the real deal,
especially when it comes to home and auto insurance.